So matrix multiplication is one of the classic examples of bulk parallelism.
Different threads can take different elements of the matrices,
multiply them all together and combine them.
Finding faces in photographs is task parallelism
because I am performing a similar operation on a large number of different input data sets.
Each photograph effectively amounts to a task, and I'm doing all of these tasks in parallel.
Binary search is a recursive algorithm.
I repeatedly look through increasingly small subsets of my data to find the value that I'm looking for,
and parallel library calls from inside of a kernel amount
to creating new parallel work inside my existing kernel parallel work,
so that is nested parallelism.